hello everyone this next game was played
between two geniuses and the genius with
the black pieces is dr. Gregory House
and the genius with the white pieces is
a young Nate who is dying of liver
failure and the entire game wasn't shown
on the show it has to be recreated so
some of the moves don't really make
sense but it's the winning combination
that matters so we have a s4 by young
Nate and as soon as he plays this a dr.
house replies oh the bird opening sign
of a coward and how to play c5 and
although this isn't really a Sicilian
defense young Mesa replies Oh a Sicilian
defense sounds a sign of an idiot and
extant in a night of 3d 5 this is the
Dutch variation of the bird opening III
Knight to f6 b3 b6 Bishop to a3 Bishop
to d6 Bishop to b5 check Knight to c6
Knight to c3 house castles and here we
have rook to b1 which is kind of a weird
move but whoever composes game probably
had had to make this rocker on b1 so the
winning combination would work so we
have E 5 by dr. house s captors on e5
and not characters on e5 and our Bishop
to e2 and the doctor has placed nice the
e4 now hanging this d5 pawn kind of
because he has a winning combination I
would have a nice captures on d5 and now
how plays nice captures an f3 would
check we have Bishop captures on f3 is G
casters on a three them Queen a
stage-four is intense checkmate after
king f1 quinta duties checkmate
so after Knight captures on a three and
exploits basic captures on history and
now dr. Haas plays Queen to h4 would
check so if the King goes to e2 then
Queen to F to bring the king of the
board so g3 and how sacrifice the bishop
bishop capture some g3 8 captures on g3
and I think after some g3 which check so
the King cannot have to go to e2 and
here dr. house plays a nice the g5 and
house says that he is winning but young
knight replied that well he plays
Queens f1 and said that house is losing
and he tells house to the winning
combination all the way to checkmate and
it's at this moment before a house makes
his next move that the young name goes
into a seizure and they takes young Nate
away and after you see a scene where dr.
house is uh well repeating the moves on
the board that young Nate has told him
previously and it goes like this Knight
captures on a three twin characters on a
three and now doctor how to play Bishop
to g4 now pinning the Queen and seems
like dr. house won the game but nice and
a young Nate has a surprise here he has
nice to e7 a very famous mating pattern
we have king to a chase and now rook
captures on h7 woods check so only move
his scheme captures on age seven and now
rook to h1 and this Knight is guarding
g8 and also a g6 so the King has nowhere
to go
black has to block either with the
bishop or with the Queen doesn't really
matter after something like Bishop to h5
simply Queen casters on h5 is checkmate
or row casters on h5 doesn't really
matter and yeah it was a beautiful game
and I was very satisfied the day
included some chess and arcane and dr.
house TV series and I think this was the
third season three at the last episode
and they should be just blessed at this
the producers I mean but then at the end
of the show when a young Nate is all
better and is leaving the hospital dr.
house stops him and he said that in this
position after Nate played the King
going to f1 the dr. house wouldn't play
Knight captures an f3 but that he
actually planned the Queen's a d6
and that he is winning the game but
there's really not a lot of sense to
this and house is down a piece and
there's really no attempt you're going
on anymore so yeah they probably just
wanted to make house appear smarter than
young Nate at the end of the show which
well someone who who tried this move on
the board can easily see that it isn't
so so yeah thank you all for watching I
hope you enjoyed this kind of weird game
although let's just leave it at the
disposition because it's much nicer ok
let's make that the last position you
guys see and yeah thank you for watching
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos
here and I would like to thank you gotta
slope through suka for a contribution to
my channel I do appreciate it thank you
a lot and that's it I'll see you guys
soon